je vais partir en Thaïlande là encore
début juillet avoir ton pote c'est la
plage
non là c'est un autre pote que je vais
voir parce que j'ai écrit un livre sur
lui donc je pars pour travailler moi le
boulot boulot
incroyable champion de moto il a
fabriqué des bateaux et après il a fait
fortune dans le Bitcoin et maintenant il
vit d'une retraite cool Samui donc je
vais le voir je vais créer un bouquin
sur sa vie
pour écraser
et après bah je reste dans ma bergerie
parce que j'ai la chance d'habiter à
l'endroit où tout le monde vont en
vacances
très bien très bien tu as toujours pas
non toujours arrêté oui oui
les filles tout arrête
calme
au niveau du terme
je suis très inquiet parce que vous
allez écrire un livre et vous avez dit
vous parlez pas français
parce que elle a raison
je pense que dans le sud comme toujours
vous savez peut-être oui parce qu'on
sera pas très loin
après mykono je dois partir 4 jours
normalement à Nicolas
en tout cas
essentiellement avec moi 80% du temps
l'année dernière il a dit qu'il
passerait il est resté quand même du
premier jour
je suis parti il était
encore là
il était dans la maison sur Paris
je reviens tout de suite je t'attends là
on va pas y aller à deux
[Rires]
laisse-moi un yaourt ou deux elle
emprunte carbone on va pas faire ça il y
a une rigolade avec Raymond l'année
dernière je vous explique l'histoire on
est à Monaco et on va
vraiment avait très envie de faire caca
donc je l'amène on s'arrête dans un
hôtel le pari euh non le Paris c'est le
pari l'Hôtel de Paris
et on arrive à l'hôtel et donc pour me
faire vivre on vient pas pour aller aux
toilettes il est là Patrick Patrick
on cherche Patrick un pote à nous et
donc là on voit et là on repère les
toilettes donc là on y va et là on
arrive aux toilettes et déjà il y a un
mec qui veut prendre un selfie avec nous
et là je dis pas tout de suite là on est
vraiment pas bien
il y avait il y avait du bon niveau les
mecs qui venaient ça ça envoyait moi
donc ça fait que je vois que dans votre
jardin
[Rires]
donc j'entendais les balles comment ça
tape fort et tout et c'est vrai que là
ils ont pas commencé et je dis waouh ou
alors il s'échauffe il y a un truc qui
va pas il me dit alors ils sont comment
ils sont bien descends ils sont bien les
100 balles va jouer tu vas voir va jouer
et descendu cette fiasco safiasco en
fait jouer ou pas quand même avec eux
nerveux je me suis mis en du balcon je
les connaissais pas les mec j'ai dit
c'est qui cette chèvres j'ai les mecs
vous me faites déplacer à 22h pour voir
ces deux chèvres là il est hors de
question que je joue avec lui et lui non
mais c'est des potes
joue avec eux et tout je suis descendu
j'ai fait trois balles avec eux un
moment plus que 3 battons
à son pote je dis écoute-moi bien arrête
de me parler parce que je vais te casser
la raquette sur la tête je ne rigole pas
l'histoire mais il a reconnu qu'il était
pas prêt parce qu'il savait pas que tu
étais aussi bon il m'a dit je savais pas
qu'il était il avait un niveau comme ça
il en avait il a dit et donc ce que j'ai
fait j'ai pris ma raquette je l'ai jeté
ou je la casse sur ta tête et je suis
parti je les ai plus jamais revu je suis
allé dès que personne ne me dérange plus
les voir du coup meilleur maintenant que
l'année dernière
et donc lui le pauvre me fait de la
peine après dans la chambre d'inviter
les gens il est venu dans ma chambre
tout nu comme ça il m'a dit je suis pas
bien ah mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
qu'elle rigole ça va ça va c'était bien
quand même franchement donc lui voilà
donc lui il sera 80% avec moi Castaldi
que tu vas faire ça je l'ai avec vous
parce que j'avais des projets mais j'ai
tout annulé là
auriez-vous des problèmes d'argent et
j'avais prévu des trucs puis finalement
dans ça ça s'annule donc je vais faire
je vais faire très light là pendant les
vacances je vais aller chez vous là je
vais vous la première semaine
non non je vais rester non je vais
rester je vais à Marseille je vais à
Marseille bah oui mais moi je peux à
Marseille ah bah je vais à Marseille
puis après je vais aller à Berkane j'ai
petite bicoque pas loin sympathique
bicoque avec plaisir une personne que
c'est un ami à moi l'animateur sympa
sympa le mec
voilà il m'a dit je crois mais c'est
modeste chez moi tu verras tout il y a
pas beaucoup de place mais je te
trouverai un petit un petit truc
sympathique à mon avis c'est bien foutu
de votre gueule et voilà et après je
crois que je pars en bateau
un copain qui a un bateau
c'est le copain du copain alors des
vacances qui tombent à l'eau
je vais m'acheter
en mode Montiel exactement
Raymond dort avec Guillaume
avec Sophie
4 4
non parce que personne dort avec moi
donc quatre coins
et après les étages
[Applaudissements]
on se voit déjà toute l'année ce qu'on a
envie de savoir
moi pour la 56e année Royan
mais tu vas tu vas te suicider quand
mais t'as pas rencontré un mec depuis 50
ans les vacances il faut pour faire des
rencontres
la journée je me baigne attends
essentiellement la piscine dans la mer
partout dès que je peux je me dois tout
desséchés
que tu vas faire bah c'est indécis
encore mais pourquoi tu cries
il m'a détruit
je sais pas encore si on part ou pas bah
à mon avis à mon avis FAT ou pas alors
je pars et on ne sait pas si elle part
elle est encore fait une esquive on sait
pas où je parle on sait pas tout c'est
la plus forte
elle a expliqué
[Rires]
voilà je les emmène sur la Côte d'Azur
si vous voulez je peux vous rendre une
petite visite si vous emmerde
moi je reste pas tellement là-bas je
serais pas tellement cette année donc
voilà c'est pas tellement cette année
j'ai pas de comment dire je serai pas
tellement et toi tu vas où ton machin
moi je vais faire les championnats du
monde à Las Vegas
en juillet
c'est quoi c'est 10000 € l'entrée ouais
10000 dollars 1000 dollars
principal c'est le meilleur
des premiers jours
mais il y a d'autres plein de tournois
et puis je vais aller au Lac me de la
cave à joue je vais voir un petit peu
enfin voilà ça va être un super
on est d'accord
il y a plein de gens qui jouent pas de
plein de joueurs de poker
hors émission c'était quoi
en rémission
jouer au casino
avec vous on dit que vous avez l'instant
du boncoin
il croyaient qu'il avait quinte oui mais
j'ai pas bien
il avait 4 5 7 7 9
et il a mis il a tout misé le gars il
est sûr qu'il va gagner et là j'arrive
il a tout perdu mais on peut faire une
revanche au poker
une semaine à New York avec ma meuf elle
reste du temps je suis open propose des
bail ma gueule
jacuzzi du plaisir saison 3
j'aimerais bien faire un foot avec Olive
olive encore ça me ferait plaisir
quand même attention c'était
extraordinaire et vous moi j'ai joué à
la pétanque je vois la pétanque si vous
voulez jouer avec des boules
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]